hey what is going on YouTube now
recently a subscriber asked David I have
a really big problem with loving myself
I know that I shouldn't say or feel
these things every morning but it's hard
how can I get over this you know one of
the hardest things that I had to deal
with is what you're going through right
now so I think there's a big
misconception of what people feel like
loving yourself is you think that loving
yourself is like you waking up every
morning and everything is [ __ ]
sunshine yeah that's not realistic
that's not like I'm not gonna tell you
[ __ ] that every day is gonna work out
the way that you want to because it's
not if that was the case I would have
won the Powerball I would be a
millionaire and right now me and a
[ __ ] unicorn will be [ __ ] [ __ ] up
but let's start off with a couple of
misconceptions that people have about
this whole term of loving yourself
loving yourself means that you're making
excuses that you're not gonna better
yourself that's not the case
loving yourself means respecting
yourself in the sense that even though
you're not perfect you are going to try
and get better every day and you are
going to improve yourself as a human
being and even if you fall short of that
it's okay there will be another day
loving yourself means that you're
conceded no I hate it when people say
that [ __ ] you know what that means it's
just a concept to saying that you are
not gonna be the first person the day
that wakes up and brings yourself down
you know I think too many people you
yourself included do that and that is a
horrible thing to deal with every day
when you wake up in the morning you are
the first person to doubt yourself how
hard is that life is not designed to be
easy it's designed to break you down but
you were designed to fight that [ __ ] but
you can't do that if you're the first
person to tell yourself and your piece
of [ __ ] do you understand that concept
every day of your life you are gonna
have to do you will walk outside the
door somebody will doubt you somebody
will tell you that you're not pretty
enough that you're not worth it that
nothing is gonna happen for you and that
you won't achieve anything yeah I'm
sorry that's what it is that's life but
for me I expect other people to think
that about me but I refuse to be the
first person to say that to myself how
are you going to reflect and say
everything that the world thinks about
you hmm you should be the person to tell
yourself in the mirror say hey you know
what you got this [ __ ] you're tight your
breasts aren't that big man boobies your
penis is perfect they're gonna mold that
[ __ ] is gonna be the hottest-selling
dildo in all of the history of
diddid there's no real how to this you
just got a really take the time to get
to know yourself and say hey you know
what I'm [ __ ] worth it and I'm not
telling you this like it's going to be
easy it was hard for me to men there was
a certain point of my life in college
where because I was wasting my parents
money and not really doing well I looked
in the mirror I was like you know what
do but why the [ __ ] are you even here
not in the sense of why are you even in
college like why the [ __ ] are you alive
what's with your existence you're just
sucking the money out of your parents
you're sitting here not bettering
yourself as a human being am I really
providing anything to society these are
hard thoughts that I thought to myself
but the difference between what I did
compared to what other people did
instead of wallowing in my self hating
hating myself every day for the way that
I was living I took that as a challenge
and I made myself better so I could look
in the mirror and say you know what I'm
proud of what you did today I'm proud
that you went out and you were proactive
and you went to better yourself instead
of looking at myself and saying you know
what I hate that person so I have to ask
you this and I always talk about
accountability what are you doing right
now what are you doing every day so that
when you wake up you are proud of what
you did the day before
because for me before I turn off this
light and I set my fast asleep I make
sure that I know that today
I accomplished something that I deserve
this sleep and the next morning I'm a
kick-ass if you have a habit of doubting
yourself in the morning then you're
gonna have to switch that routine up my
friends yeah I know that it's [ __ ]
easier said than done and we could talk
about all the negatives of why that
saying doesn't make sense there's
somebody else out there that has a
better than you well guess what
there's also people out there who
haven't worse than you or experiencing
something similar to what you're doing
and they're doing okay they're perfectly
fine so just deal with that think about
that and suck on that what I'm saying
kid is that you'll be fine look at me
when I started doing stand-up comedy my
dad looked at me and said oh you want to
be poor and what did I say I said you
know what daddy whoo